hey leute willkommen zur ersten texture
pack vorstellung ich habe ja mal ein
video gemacht was meine lieblings texte
packs für die version 1.3 punkt 2 sind
und da habt ihr ja fleißig darunter
geschrieben dass ich doch mal so eine
serie
vielleicht starten soll vielleicht mal
schauen soll was daraus wir die ihr das
recht findet und euch vielleicht texture
pack zeige dir eventuell schon kennt
aber vielleicht doch ziemlich viel oder
einige von euch noch nicht kennen und
zwar ist das heutige heute vorgestellte
texture pack das außer die peg von disco
ihr kennt wahrscheinlich oder ihr
solltet den kanal fv disco kennen das
sind engländer amerikaner franzosen ich
weiß es nicht irgendwie sowas in die
richtung keine ahnung jeden fall zeigen
die in ihren videos teilweise so naja
was zeigen die zeigen so redstone
schaltungen spiele die sie in minecraft
entwickelt haben und dazu passt
natürlich auch so ein text cab ecke
denkt euch wahrscheinlich erstmal was
soll das was denn das für ein kack viele
texturen sind gleich geblieben wie zum
beispiel die von den schafen die von dem
wasser weiß ich gar nicht ob die gleiche
ist ja ich glaube auch oder oder die vom
wassers auch gleich behalten weil ich
mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher dieser auf
einmal so anders aus aber die ganze
blöcke sind halt echt voneinander
getrennt durch diese dicken balken hier
das inventar hier ist alles komplett
anders sage ich mal
das ist einfach weil die das alles so
ein bisschen simpel halten wollte
irgendwelche redstone schaltungen und
ihr seht echt alle blöcke sind hier
extrem voneinander getrennt die blätter
hier das sieht alles echt so ein
bisschen
ich sag mal vernachlässigt gezeichnet
aus aber ich finde das eigentlich ganz
gut und zwar fest normale let's play
weiß ich nicht was ich davon halten soll
muss sich zeigen ob man damit irgendwie
klar kommt allerdings für redstone
schaltungen perfekt ich meine ich habe
schon im inventar so ein paar sachen
vorbereitet so holz so dass sich alles
gar nicht so toll aus aber wenn man
irgendwie wolle hinsetzt oder so
das kann man so was von leicht
unterscheiden das feld einfach richtig
auf wenn der landschaft wenn ich jetzt
1000 meter weit weg fliegen würde würde
ich trotzdem dass sie erkennen weil das
einfach alles so leuchtet ich hab mir
dann auch schon mal ein bisschen
redstone drauf gepackt ich bin kein
redstone experte
ich könnte mit damit vielleicht mal
beschäftigen wenn ihr das irgendwie
wollt oder so dass sich ein paar videos
oder tutorials mache aber egal
jedenfalls seht ihr schon es ist
eigentlich ein text speck gedacht für
redstone schaltungen also diese ganzen
sachen kann man echt gut erkennen dass
man dann zum beispiel wenn man was
großes baut zum beispiel hier eine spur
nur aus diesem grünen material macht das
der grünen wolle dann wieder so rum dann
geht da oben seinem letzten schnell her
dann wieder eins aus dem roten also fürs
let's play will ich das touch pack
eigentlich eher weniger empfehlen muss
man halt gucken ob man das will das
texture pack fürs let's play oder keine
ahnung jedenfalls wird ich sagen dass
das eigentlich viel mehr
ein text gepäck ist was für irgendwelche
redstone schaltungen oder spiele
mechaniken behind the scenes gedacht ist
also ich finde ja wenn ihr irgendwelche
redstone schaltung macht dann holt euch
auf jeden fall das texture pack und
macht nicht mit
default weil wenn ich das mal kurz will
hier guckt mal nicht wirklich mal kurz
auf die faul texture pack das sieht
alles ziemlich triste aus natürlich die
landschaft und so an sich alles schöner
und beweglicher vor allem mit diesem
spot allerdings finde ich dass man das
nicht so gut erkennen kann mit dem
redstone als wie wenn ich jetzt das hier
auswähle kann man schon besser kennen
diese redstone schaltungen also dass das
texture pack wofür ich es empfehlen
würde ich würde dem texture pack acht
von zehn diamanten geben ganz einfach
warum nur acht von zehn ein diamant
abzug weil nicht alle texturen
verfeinert wurden das heißt zum beispiel
kühe oder ähnlich in die kühe wurden
glaube ich doch übernommen aber scharfe
oder sowas wurde nicht in das texture
pack übernommen die sind einfach so
gelassen worden genauso wie mops und so
weiter und der zweite - punkt ist dass
erde und so alles auch diese komischen
linien striche unter sich besetzung
dieses gras liegt auch ein bisschen
komisch aus also das hätten sie auch ein
wenig verändert verändern können von mir
aus am rand so abgetrennt lassen aber
oben nicht weil das die aus wie sonne
wie so ein text ränder fehler von
minecraft und das sieht halt nicht ganz
so toll aus also ich gebe den texture
pack acht von zehn diamanten lasst mich
in den kommentaren wissen welches
texture pack ich vielleicht als nächstes
vorstellen soll und wie ihr meine
bewertung findet bzw
das texture pack bewerten würde ich
würde mich über domhof freuen und ich
habe mir gedacht dass ich euch jetzt
noch ein paar szenen zeigen die ich mit
dem die volltexte pack und danach mit
diesem text speck aufgenommen habe also
lasst mich eure meinung in den
kommentaren bis zu diesen diensten
wirtschaft
the day